Donald Trump has fired off in angry
tweets over revelations there was
high-level talk to have him removed from
office in it he quotes the views of
Harvard Law Professor Emeritus Alan
Dershowitz who happens to be the latest
guest on our T's worlds apart show the
host of which Roxanna boy Koch joins me
live now in the studio I've sounded good
to see you now apparently this talk to
have Trump removed focus on the 25th
amendment did Dershowitz comment on the
legality of this yes absolutely
we talked a lot about it and this whole
discussion was triggered by the latest
revelations by former FBI deputy chief
Andrew McCabe who on record admitted
that the Justice Department officials
indeed considered back in 2017 invoking
the 25th amendment to remove Donald
Trump from office now that amendment
provides for a process of discharging a
sitting president if he is mentally or
physically incapacitated but according
to Alan Dershowitz this bhai no means
applies to Trump because he's physically
fit you may disagree with his policies
and a lot of people do but that is not
the ground for invoking this amendment
and according to some people on the
Trump side that was as close as the
United States has ever come to an
administrative coup when a group of
unelected security officials get
together and discuss removing
democratically elected president from
office which is which was according to
josephus an abuse of power well let's
listen to what he had to say
well terrible abuse of the Constitution
the Constitution provides for
impeachment that's a political legal
remedy but the 25th amendment was
designed for people who had a stroke or
President Reagan when he was shot when
you're incapacitated when you're
unconscious when you're unable to be the
president it provides a mechanism for
replacing the president with the vice
president it was never intended to be
used to rid the country of a president
who people don't agree with who they
think may have committed obstruction of
justice
our collaboration with Russia well we
know Trump faces more pressure in the
form of the ongoing Muller investigation
into alleged Russian collusion so what
did dish would say about this he was
very critical of the way the Miller
investigation is being carried out
because remember almost two years into
this probe we still don't have a single
indictment that relates to the regional
crime that it was supposed to
investigate which is the collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians we have a number of indictments
based on the so-called processed crimes
when you arrest the person when you
interrogate him when you some or her
when he's essentially set up a moral
trap to see if he would lie to the
prosecutors and indeed a couple of
people did but none of them was or has
been charged with being directly
involved with the Russians and one one
interesting point that Dershowitz made
it makes is that even if Trump
administration officials had some
contacts with the Russians having a
contact in and of itself is not enough
to support the collusion charge well
first of all even if there were
collusion between the Trump campaign and
some Russians that would not be a crime
it's not a crime to collude it would be
a crime only if members of the Trump
campaign or any campaign urged people in
another country to commit a crime like
hacking the emails of their opponents
the Democratic National Committee but
there's no evidence of that at all and I
suspect in the end what they'll find is
there was some people in the campaign
who had contacts with some people in
Russian intelligence perhaps some
contact with WikiLeaks and contact with
others but they're not going to be able
to make a case for the government of
Russia
colluding illegally with the
presidential candidate Donald Trump we
are running this interview in full this
coming Sunday and I think it raises a
number of very interesting points about
the lengths to which some Americans are
willing to go to remove Trump from
office and what their will
to sacrifice in the process of doing
that which according to Dersch width is
the Constitution and the rule of law
you